Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now you can discover Canada and their many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is,
有些旅行在爱彼迎上体验会更好。现在，你可以在爱彼迎上探索加拿大及其众多鲜为人知的本地宝藏。我曾在加拿大断断续续工作了两年。是的。在第一年，剧组给我安排了一个住处。到了第二年，我想，不管那个制作预算是多少，
can I have it and go find my own place in more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes. And I did, I got an Airbnb, I got a little apartment, it faced a park, it was so lovely. I loved the host and I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah, and I was near a grocery store.
能不能把钱给我，让我自己去找个更有人情味的社区住处呢？可以的。我照做了，我租了一套爱彼迎的小公寓，正对着一个公园，非常可爱。我很喜欢房东，并在那里住了两个月。哇。是的，而且我离杂货店很近。
I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know, it just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there. You know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff National Park.
我真的觉得我在那里过上了自己的小生活。我在想加拿大的落基山脉地区，那里有湖泊和艾伯塔落基山脉。不知道为什么，就觉得如果你能在那里拥有一个小巧温馨的小木屋。你知道我的意思吗？是的。就像班夫国家公园一样。
Well listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
听着，也许你应该为你的下一次冒险考虑一下爱彼迎。我是说，我们非常喜欢。超爱。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. The Finer Things Club is the most exclusive club in this office. Naturally, it's where I need to be.
现在我们专门为你带来终极办公室爱 好者播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节以及大量VFF的故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妹6.0。精美物品俱乐部是这个办公室里最专属的俱乐部。理所当然，这也是我应该去的地方。
The party planning committee is my backup and Kevin's band is my safety. Hello everyone. Hi, we are so excited because today on Office Ladies 6.0, it's a meeting of the finer things club. Okay, so I loved doing the finer things club storyline so much, it's one of my favorite office memories. I'm so excited to talk about it today.
派对策划委员会是我的后盾，凯文的乐队是我的安全网。大家好。嗨，我们非常兴奋，因为今天是办公室辣妹6.0的精美物品俱乐部会议。好吧，我太喜欢做精美物品俱乐部的剧情线了，这是我最喜欢的《办公室》记忆之一。我今天特别高兴能聊聊这个。
I wanted to be in the finer things club. So I'm very excited today I about it today. I wanted to be in the Fighter Things Club. So I'm very excited today I get to be an honorary member. Yes, that's right. Because today we are going to talk a little bit about Dunder Mifflin's Fighter Things Club, but we're also going to dive into the world of book clubs and book club dramas. Angela, I believe you did a deep dive
我想加入精致生活俱乐部。所以我今天非常高兴我能成为一名荣誉会员。是的，没错。因为今天我们要稍微聊聊邓德米夫林的精致生活俱乐部，但我们也将深入探讨读书俱乐部和读书俱乐部狗血剧的世界。安吉拉，我相信你对下午茶的起源进行了深入研究。
on the origins of afternoon tea. I did. You know I can't wait for that. It was so fun. And Jenna, you've been so excited for this episode because you're a super book nerd and you've got lots to share. Oh, I am in my happy place today. Cassie, I know you as well.
是的，我做了。你知道我对此期待已久。太有趣了。珍娜，你一直对这一集感到非常兴奋，因为你是个超级书呆子，而且有很多内容要分享。哦，我今天简直置身于快乐的天堂。卡西，我也很了解你。
Yes, this is very true. I love reading. It's not to say that Sam and I don't love reading. It's a little harsh, but all right. Did you feel it? Did you feel it? A little smug opening? Sure. Well, as you all know, The Finer Things Club was revealed in season four, episode 10 of The Office, titled Branch Wars.
是的，这千真万确。我喜欢阅读。这并不是说萨姆和我 不喜欢阅读。这话有点刺耳，不过好吧。你感觉到了吗？你感觉到了吗？有点自以为是的开场？当然。好吧，如你所知，精致生活俱乐部是在《办公室》第四季第10集《分公司大战》中被揭晓的。
This episode introduces the club as a very exclusive group within the Scranton branch. It has three members, Pam Beasley, Oscar Martinez, and Toby Flenderson. And let me tell you, Toby is not interested on having anyone else join. No, he is not. Well, there are rules for the finer things club. It's very organized. And here's a clip of Pam explaining how it all works. Oscar, Toby and I are founding members of the finer things club. We meet once a month to discuss books and art, celebrate culture in a very civilized way. Sometimes the debate can get heated,
这一集将该俱乐部介绍为斯克兰顿分公司内部一个非常独特的团体。它有三名成员，帕姆·比斯利、奥斯卡·马丁内斯和托比·弗兰德森。而且我得告诉你，托比对让任何人加入都不感兴趣。不，他才不呢。好吧，精致生活俱乐部是有规则的。它非常井井有条。这里有一个帕姆解释这一切是如何运作的片段。奥斯卡、托比和我是精致生活俱乐部的前三名创始成员。我们每月聚会一次，讨论书籍和艺术，以一种非常文明的方式庆祝文化。有时辩论会变得很激烈，
but we're always respectful. There is no paper, no plastic, and no work talk allowed. It's very exclusive. Look at how happy she is. It's very exclusive. Just so hoity-toity. I mean, I think she's just proud of her little group. I think she is proud, but I also think she's hoity-toity. My goodness.
但我们总是互相尊重。这里没有纸制品，没有塑料制品，也不允许谈论工作。非常独家。看她多高兴。非常独家。就是那种自命不凡的感觉。我的意思是，我觉得她只是为她的小团体感到骄傲。我觉得她是感到骄傲，但我也觉得她自命不凡。天哪。
Well, you know, things are going very well for our little finer things club group until Andy decides he wants to be a member. And then later, Pam lets Jim into the group. You know, she feels bad for him. And he's clearly not read the book Angela's Ashes. Drama, drama. And you guys, we were all talking and we realize any book club we've heard of, there's always some drama.
好吧，你知道的，我们精致生活俱乐部的小团体一切都进行得非常顺利，直到安迪决定他想成为一名会员。然后后来，帕姆让吉姆加入了这个俱乐部。你知道的，她为他感到难过。而且他明显没有读过安吉拉的书《安吉拉的灰烬》。狗血，太狗血了。而且伙计们，我们一直在讨论，并意识到我们听说的任何读书俱乐部，总是少不了一些狗血剧情。
And we reached out to you guys and you wrote in with your book club drama stories and you definitely confirmed our theory. For example, we got this letter from Colleen C. in Pittsburgh, which I just loved. Here it is. Colleen said, I attended a snooty book club similar to the finer things club. See? Snooty. I was invited by a friend and didn't realize how exclusive it was. They rotated hosts each month and the host had to provide the food, venue, and drinks.
我们联系了你们，你们发来了你们的读书俱乐部狗血故事，这绝对证实了我们的理论。例如，我们收到了匹兹堡的科琳·C.发来的这封信，我太喜欢了。就是这封。科琳说，我参加了一个类似于精致生活俱乐部的高傲读书俱乐部。看？高傲。我受朋友邀请去的，当时并没有意识到它是多么具有独家性。他们每个月轮流由一个人做东，做东的人必须提供食物、场地和饮料。
The host would be silently judged on what they were able to provide. And if it wasn't up to standards, would be openly critiqued in the group chat. Oh my gosh. This is a book club Angela would like. Well, she would love the judging. Yes. Colleen said the books selected were long and intellectual.
东道主会被无声地评判他们所能提供的食物是否达标，如果没有达到标准，会在群聊中被公开批判。哦天哪。这是一个安吉拉会喜欢的读书俱乐部。嗯，她会喜欢这种评判的。是的。科琳说选择的书籍既长又很有学术性。
The discussion was very formal. At the end of the night, we would all go around and rate the book from one to five. Members were encouraged to be extremely careful in rating a book a five and should only do so if the book had quote, changed their life. Eventually, the original members decided the book club was getting too big.
讨论非常正式。夜晚结束时，大家会聚在一起给这本书打分，从一到五分。鼓励成员在给一本书打五分时要极其谨慎，只有当这本书“改变了他们的人生”时才能这么做。最终，最初的成员决定读书俱乐部变得太大了。
They were mad that people were just inviting their friends without any sort of vetting process. They met together and selected who would be kicked out of the book club. All members being kicked out received a formal phone call letting them know they were no longer welcome to attend. I ended up being kicked out, but my friend warned me in advance
他们很生气，因为人们在没有任何审查程序的情况下就把朋友拉了进来。他们开会决定了谁将被踢出读书俱乐部。所有被踢出的成员都接到了正式电话，告知他们不再受欢迎。我最后被踢出去了，但我的朋友提前警告了我，
and I ignored the call out of spite. They called several times before finally resigning to the fact that they'd have to inform me of my removal over voicemail. All of us who were kicked out started our own book club with less pressure and less rules. Oh my goodness. So snooty.
出于赌气，我没有接那个电话。他们打了好几次电话，最后只好无奈地通过语音留言通知我被开除了。我们所有被开除的人成立了自己的读书俱乐部，压力更小，规矩也更少。哦天哪。太自命不凡了。
Well, you know who has a book club, lady. Who has a book club? The writer of Branch Wars, Mindy Kaling. Oh yes, of course she does. And I guess everyone can join her book club so it's not snooty. I went to the website for it and this is what it says. Fresh, vibrant and binge-worthy reads.
好吧，你知道谁有一个读书俱乐部吗，女士。谁有一个读书俱乐部？《分公司大战》的编剧，明迪·卡灵。哦，是的，她当然有。我想任何人都可以加入她的读书俱乐部，所以它一点也不高傲。我访问了它的网站，上面是这样写的。新鲜、充满活力且让人欲罢不能的读物。
Mindy's Book Studio celebrates emerging and diverse voices from fresh romantic comedies and poignant coming-of-age stories to suspenseful dramas with unforgettable female protagonists. And then there's a quote from Mindy. It says, I'm passionate about bringing unique stories to readers and viewers,
明迪图书工作室赞助新兴和多元的声音，从新鲜的浪漫喜剧、感人的成长故事到拥有令人难忘的女主角的悬念剧。然后还有明迪的一句名言。上面说，我热衷于为读者和观众带来独特的故事，
and I can't wait to help discover and support talented new voices through Mindy's Book Studio. Right now, they're spotlighting eight books, and I'll put them in our stories. I love this. I know. I love the idea of starting a book club. But the follow-through sounds kind of daunting to me. Well, lady, I have a little surprise
我迫不及待地想要通过明迪图书工作室去发掘和支持有才华的新声音。现在，他们正在重点推广八本书，我会把它们发到我们的动态里。我太喜欢这个了。我懂。我也喜欢发起一个读书俱乐部的想法。但后续的坚持对我来说听起来有点让人望而却步。好吧，女士，我今天给我们的办公室辣妹小分队准备了一个小惊喜。
for our office ladies group today. Are you starting a book club? I'm not starting a book club, but I do have a passion for reading. Lady, you gave me that amazing book club membership for my birthday from that independent bookstore. So I thought maybe it would be fun to surprise each of you today with one of my favorite books.
你是在发起一个读书俱乐部吗？我没有发起读书俱乐部，但我确实对阅读充满热情。女士，你送给我的那份来自独立书店的生日礼物，就是那个棒极了的读书俱乐部会员资格。所以我想，今天用我最喜欢的书之一给你们每个人一个惊喜，也许会很有趣。
Oh, that's wonderful. That I have fun to surprise each of you today with one of my favorite books. Oh, that's wonderful! That I have hand selected for each of you. Oh, so we have a different one? Yes. Ah, this sounds so cool. Now this is a book that is a gift to me or a task that I now have to read.
哦，那太棒了！我为你们每个人精心挑选了一本。哦，所以我们每个人都不一样？是的。啊，听起来太酷了。现在这是一本作为礼物送给我的书，还是我现在的阅读任务？
It is a gift. Okay. But Sam, your phrasing says everything. Yeah, when does this do? Cassie, turn around. There is a red wrapped item on the shelf behind you. This is your book gift. This is like the matrix where there's things
这是一份礼物。好吧。但萨姆，你的措辞说明了一切。是的，这书什么时候读完？卡西，转过身去。你身后的书架上有一个红色的包裹。这是你的书本礼物。这就像《黑客帝国》一样，里面有些东西，
and you're like, what? That's been there the whole time? Yeah, I had no idea. I just lead everything back to Keon. All right, I'm opening it. All right. Now, Cassie, I know you read a lot. It was very hard for me to think of a book
然后你会想，什么？那东西一直在那儿吗？是的，我完全不知道。我把所有事情都跟基恩联系起来。好了，我要打开它了。好的。卡西，我知道你读了很多书。要我想出一本你可能没读过的书，对我来说太难了。所以你可能已经读过这本书了。是什么？
that maybe you hadn't read. So you may have already read this. What is it? It is 112263 by Stephen King. Oh, that's a really good one. It is one of my all time favorite books. It's not horror, but there is a fantasy time travel element. Here's what it's about.
斯蒂芬·金的《11/22/63》。哦，那真的是一本好书。它是我有史以来最喜欢的书之一。它不是恐怖小说，但里面有奇幻的时空旅行元素。故事是这样的。
The main character discovers a portal where he can go back in time, and he decides that he's going to try and stop the assassination of John F. Kennedy. This sounds amazing. Have you read it? I have not read it. My partner has read it.
主角发现了一个可以回到过去的入口，他决定尝试阻止对约翰·F·肯尼迪的暗杀。这听起来太棒了。你读过吗？我没读过。我伴侣读过。
But years ago, when we'd go on walks, he was telling me the plot. Oh, no. So you know the plot. But he told me this over five years ago. Oh no, so you know the plot. But he told me this like over five years ago. I remember a little bit about a romance, but everything else I don't remember.
但几年前，当我们去散步时，他跟我讲过这个情节。哦，不。所以你知道情节。但他五年前就跟我说过这个了。哦，不，所以你知道情节。但这是他五年多前跟我说的。我只记得一点点关于浪漫的事，其他什么都不记得了。
You know what, Cassie? The romance is my favorite part of the book. I'm telling you this book, it's like beautiful. It's beautiful, and also the past is obdurate. What does that mean? What's obdurate? Is that what he says over and over? What's that word mean? Ob that what he says over and over? What's that word mean?
你知道吗，卡西？浪漫部分是我整本书最喜欢的部分。我跟你说这本书，它太美了。太美了，而且“过去是顽固的”。那是什么意思？什么是“顽固”？这是他一遍又一遍说的话吗？那个词是什么意思？那是他一遍又一遍说的话吗？那个词是什么意思？
Obdurate. It means the past is unmovable. Oh. It's the phrase that stuck with me after I read it. I'm so intellectual of you. Oh, I guess you're surprised. You know what stuck with me is there's a moment where he drinks root beer and it like, I don't know, the way it was described
顽固。意思就是过去是无法改变的。哦。这就是我读完后一直印在脑海里的短语。你可真有学术气息啊。哦，我猜你很惊讶。你知道印在我脑海里的是什么吗？有一个情节是他喝了根汁汽水，然后，我不知道，那种描述方式就像是我最喜欢的段落之一。
was like one of my favorite passages. Obdurate, stubbornly refusing to change one's opinion or course of action. Oh, that's a little hint. All right, but that's the phrase he says over and over. Jenna, what? I'll be tracking it as I read it. Okay.
顽固，意指顽固地拒绝改变自己的观点或行事方式。哦，这算是一个小提示。好吧，但这就是他反复说的那句话。珍娜，什么？我读的时候会留意这个词的。好的。
Thank you so much, Jenna. I can tell Jenna's in her happy place because we've been friends a really long time and she does this thing with her hands when she's feeling a little like festive and fancy. She does like this little like, I don't know, you can't see me because I'm on a podcast, but I'll do it and I'll put it in stories.
非常感谢你，珍娜。我能看出珍娜现在正处于她的快乐小天地里，因为我们认识很久了，当她感到有点喜庆和精致时，她就会用手做这个动作。她会做那种小小的，我不知道，你看不到我，因为我是在录播客，但回头我会做这个动作并发布到动态里。
Okay, Sam, would you like to turn around and get your red wrapped gift? I would, thank you. Okay, here it goes. I'm not familiar with this. I'm familiar with the author and my year of rest and relaxation. You've read my year of rest and relaxation?
好的，萨姆，你想转过身去拿你的红色包装礼物吗？我想，谢谢。好吧，开始了。我对这个不太熟悉。我对作者很熟悉，还有她的《我的一年休息和放松》。你读过《我的一年休息和放松》？
I have, yes. Okay, so Sam, that is one of the most original, weird books I've ever read in my life. Agreed. Okay, this book is her new book, Lepvana. Lepvana. The author is Otessa Moschveg. And it is set in a fictional medieval town.
是的，我读过。好吧，萨姆，那是我这辈子读过的最原创、最古怪的书之一。完全同意。好吧，这本书是她的新书，《莱普瓦纳》。莱普瓦纳。作者是奥特莎·莫什韦格。故事背景设定在一个虚构的中世纪小镇。
It's about how this lowly sheep farmer and then the Lord that lives on the hill interact. It is so bizarre and wonderful. I absolutely loved it. I think you're gonna like it. Well, it says in the back, it will scorch you like a blowtorch from John Waters. And I love John Waters.
讲的是一个卑微的牧羊人与住在山上的领主之间的互动。这书太离奇又太精彩了。我超级喜欢。我想你会喜欢的。好吧，封底上写着，“它会像喷灯一样灼伤你”，来自约翰·沃特斯。我喜欢约翰·沃特斯。
So anything that he recommends, I'm in. Thank you so much. This is killer. Yay. All right, Angela, it's your turn. I am giving you a summer beach read by one of my favorite authors. Here you go. I love a summer beach read by one of my favorite authors. Here you go.
所以他推荐的任何东西，我都买账。非常谢谢你。这太棒了。耶。好了，安吉拉，轮到你了。我要送你一本我最喜欢的作家写的夏日沙滩读物。给你。我喜欢我最喜欢的作家写的夏日沙滩读物。给你。
I love a summer beach read. This is by Taylor Jenkins Reid. Carrie Soto is back. And it looks like she's really tan and in a bathing suit. She's arching her neck up to the sky. Well, guess what? You know who Carrie Soto is? She's a retired pro tennis player who comes out of retirement at 37 years old to reclaim her title. Hell yeah. As the best female tennis player of all time. I think you're going to like it. I cannot wait. I'm in. Woohoo! Thank you. That was so thoughtful. Oh, guys, I've just been so excited about today. We're going to talk books. We're going to talk book club dramas.
我喜欢夏日沙滩读物。这是泰勒·詹金斯·里德写的。《凯瑞·索托回来了》。看起来她皮肤晒得很黑，穿着泳衣。她正把脖子向天空仰起。好吧，你猜怎么着？你知道凯瑞·索托是谁吗？她是一位退役的职业网球运动员，在37岁时复出，试图夺回她作为史上最佳女子网球运动员的头衔。太棒了。我想你会喜欢的。我迫不及待了。我加入。呜呼！谢谢。太贴心了。哦，伙计们，我今天太兴奋了。我们要聊书。我们要聊读书俱乐部的狗血剧。
We're going to talk finer things. Tea party. I mean, lady, you're all dressed up. I got all dressed up. Both of you look really nice today. Thank you. I wore a little pink dress. Jenna is in this really pretty black blouse with pants and high heels.
我们要聊精致生活。茶会。我是说，女士，你打扮得真漂亮。我盛装打扮了一番。你们俩今天看起来都很棒。谢谢。我穿了一条粉色的小裙子。珍娜穿着这件非常漂亮的黑色衬衫，搭配裤子和高跟鞋。
Sort of high heels. Sort of. They're like sneaker heels. They're really cool. They're called sneaks. Sneaks. S-N-E-E-X. Snicks. Snicks? Sneaks.
算是高跟鞋吧。差不多。它们就像运动鞋高跟鞋。真的很酷。它们叫Sneaks。Sneaks。S-N-E-E-X。Snicks。Snicks？Sneaks。
I don't know. And yeah, I saw them online. They were fed to me in an Instagram algorithm and I bought them and I like them. They're the only heels I can wear. They look like sneakers, but they have a high heel. Okay, this is not an ad, I'm telling you, but I bought my shoes
我不知道。是的，我在网上看到的。它们是通过Instagram算法推荐给我的，我买了，而且我很喜欢。这是我唯一能穿的高跟鞋。它们看起来像运动鞋，但有高跟。好吧，这不是广告，我跟你说，但我买我的鞋
because I saw them in an Instagram ad. I'm not making this up, I'm going to take them off. They're little slides and they're called Archies, and they're good if you have high arches and they feel comfy with my plantar fasciitis. So yeah. Would you like to know that my pants also came from Instagram? and they feel comfy with my plantar fasciitis. So yeah. Would you like to know that my pants also came from Instagram
是因为我在Instagram广告上看到了它们。我没有瞎编，我要把它们脱下来。它们是那种凉拖，叫Archies，如果你有高足弓的话穿这个很好，而且对于我的足底筋膜炎来说穿起来很舒服。所以是的。你们想知道我的裤子也是从Instagram买来的吗？而且对于我的足底筋膜炎来说穿起来很舒服。所以是的。你们想知道我的裤子也是从Instagram买来的吗？
from a designer named Kia Tomlin and I freaking love them. There you go. So look at us. Look at us. Getting finer things on the gram. Like responding strongly to our algorithms. Well, listen, why don't we take a break and when we come back, we're gonna share more of your book club dramas as well as our algorithms. Well, listen, why don't we take a break and when we come back, we're going to share more
来自一个叫基亚·汤姆林的设计师，我超级喜欢它们。就是这样。所以看看我们。看看我们。在Instagram上过着精致生活。就像对我们的算法做出强烈反应一样。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下，等回来后，我们来分享更多你们的读书俱乐部狗血剧以及我们的算法。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下，等回来后，我们来分享更多
of your book club dramas as well as our own. And I also want to play some deleted talking heads from Branch Wars. It's everyone reacting to the finer things club. Oh, I can't wait. All right, we'll be back. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Lady, did you see that hilarious Saturday Night Live sketch they did about men's health and mental health where, like, in order to trick men into taking care of themselves,
你们的读书俱乐部狗血剧以及我们自己的故事。我还想播放一些来自《分公司大战》中被删减的“说话的头”片段。那是每个人对精致生活俱乐部的反应。哦，我等不及了。好的，我们马上回来。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。女士，你看到周六夜现场那个关于男性健康和心理健康的搞笑小品了吗？在那里，为了诱使男人照顾好自己，
they made a medical clinic that is like a podcast, like a Dude Bro podcast. Oh my gosh, it's so funny. But it's also because it's kinda true. Men are often reluctant to take the time to dig into their mental health. I've got a stat for you. Six million men in the US suffer from depression every year and it's often undiagnosed.
他们建立了一个医疗诊所，就像一个播客，就像一个直男兄弟播客。哦天哪，太搞笑了。但这也是因为这有点真实。男人往往不愿花时间去深入了解他们的心理健康。我手头有个数据。美国每年有六百万男性患有抑郁症，而且往往没有被诊断出来。
So listen, if you're a man and you're feeling the weight of the world, we would like to encourage you to talk to someone. A friend, a loved one, a therapist. Maybe you want to give BetterHelp a try. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp.
所以听着，如果你是一个男人，正感受到世界的重压，我们想鼓励你跟某人谈谈。一个朋友、一个爱人、一个治疗师。也许你想试试BetterHelp。作为全球最大的在线心理治疗提供商，BetterHelp可以让你接触到拥有各种专业知识的心理健康专业人士。向BetterHelp倾诉吧。
Our listeners get 10% off their first month at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's betterhelp.com slash office ladies. Whether it's a family member, friend, or furry companion joining your summer road trip, enjoy the peace of mind that comes with Volvo's legendary safety. During Volvo Discover Days, enjoy limited time savings as you make plans to cruise through Muskoka or down Toronto's bustling streets. From now until June 30th, lease a 2025 Volvo XC60 from 1.74% and save up to $4,000. Conditions apply. Visit your GTA Volvo retailer or go to volvocars.ca for full details.
我们的听众在betterhelp.com斜杠office ladies可以享受首月九折优惠。网址是betterhelp.com斜杠office ladies。无论是家庭成员、朋友还是毛茸茸的同伴加入您的夏日公路旅行，都能享受沃尔沃传奇安全性带来的安心。在沃尔沃探索日期间，当您计划游历穆斯科卡或穿梭于多伦多繁华街道时，享受限时优惠。从即日起至6月30日，租赁2025款沃尔沃XC60，利率低至1.74%，最高可省4000美元。须受条款及细则约束。请访问您的GTA沃尔沃零售商或登录volvocars.ca了解完整详情。
Welcome back, everyone. You know, before we dive into all of our book club dramas, office and non-office related, should we discuss a book club win, a very big book club win? Yeah, we should, because our very own Cassie has a huge book club win. You just posted you won a giant trophy for reading the most books in a year. Yes, this is correct. Cassie has a huge book club win. You just posted you won a giant trophy for
欢迎大家回来。你知道，在我们深入探讨我们所有的读书俱乐部狗血剧（办公室和非办公室相关）之前，我们是不是应该讨论一个读书俱乐部的胜利，一个非常大的读书俱乐部胜利？是的，我们应该讨论，因为我们自己的卡西就取得了巨大的读书俱乐部胜利。你刚刚发帖说你赢得了一个巨大的奖杯，因为你在一年里读了最多的书。是的，这是真的。卡西取得了巨大的读书俱乐部胜利。你刚刚发帖说你赢得了一个巨大的奖杯，因为
reading the most books in a year? Yes, this is correct. So your book club gave you a trophy? Like how did it work? So I've been in this book club for maybe five years and it's a competitive book reading club. It's like I'll show you the spreadsheet but it's like based on what you read, how many like pages it is, the genre, you get a certain amount of points. And it like encourages diverse reading, which is really cool. Like, I've read a lot of books from different countries and like, they make sure you're reading a lot of women and stuff like that, which is really great. Yeah. And then last year I was like, I really want to win this thing. And I was neck and neck with
你在一年里读了最多的书？是的，这是真的。所以你的读书俱乐部给了你一个奖杯？这是怎么运作的？我加入这个读书俱乐部大概五年了，这是一个竞争激烈的图书阅读俱乐部。就像我给你们看电子表格一样，它是根据你读的书、有多少页、类型来决定的，你会得到一定数量的分数。它鼓励多元化阅读，这真的很酷。比如，我读过很多不同国家的书，而且他们确保你读了很多女性作家的书之类的内容，这真的很棒。是的。然后去年我想，我真的想赢得这个比赛。我和另一个读者不相上下，
another reader and I ended up winning, which was very cool. But also I felt crazy. How many books did you read to win this title? So I read over 66 books last year. Wow. That's more than one a week. Yeah. And some of them, like you don't get as many points
最后我赢了，这非常酷。但我也觉得自己疯了。为了赢得这个头衔，你读了多少本书？去年我读了66本以上的书。哇。那比一周一本还要多。是的。有些书，虽然你拿不到那么多分数，
but you can read like audio books or mangas, graphic novels. So I do that a lot on top of reading like a novel. Oh, my gosh. Did you just have so many stories in your head? Because like when I read, I sit for a while with stuff, you know, and I think about it like, how did that feel? Yeah, I think if it was a book I wasn't in love with, I would pick up the pace. But if I love a book, I will really take my time and sit in it. And I love a Saturday morning reading for a couple hours on the couch with a cat is one of my favorite things to do.
但你可以读有声书或者漫画、图像小说。所以在读小说的同时，我也经常这样做。哦，天哪。你的脑子里怎么能装下这么多故事？因为像我读书的时候，我会花一段时间去沉浸在书里的东西中，你知道的，我会思考它——那种感觉是怎样的？是的，我想如果那是一本我不太喜欢的书，我会加快阅读速度。但如果我喜欢一本书，我真的会放慢节奏，细细品味。我喜欢周六早晨在沙发上就着猫咪读上几个小时的书，这是我最喜欢做的事情之一。
So of all the books that you read, is there a favorite? I think in the beginning of the year, I read Octavia Butler for the first time. I really loved the world she built. And, like, she's from Pasadena, which is really cool, too. So I really enjoyed her. And I also really like this Japanese detective author. His name's Keigo Higashino. Devotion of Suspect X.
所以在你读过的所有书里，有没有最喜欢的一本？我想在今年年初，我第一次读了奥克塔维娅·巴特勒的书。我真的很喜欢她构建的世界。而且，她来自帕萨迪纳，这也真的很酷。所以我真的很喜欢她。我也非常喜欢这位日本侦探小说家。他叫东野圭吾。《嫌疑人X的献身》。
That's the one that got me into him. And then I recommended it to my book club, and, like, half of them have read it now. And then I recommended it to my book club, and like half of them have read it now. And I've read like several of his books, because they always take place in a different part of Japan. And it's really cool. That's so great. Okay, wait, I have to ask.
就是这本书让我开始迷上他的。然后我把它推荐给了我的读书俱乐部，现在他们有一半的人都读过了。然后我把它推荐给了我的读书俱乐部，现在他们有一半的人都读过了。而且我已经读过他好几本书了，因为它们的故事总是发生在日本不同的地方。真的很酷。太棒了。等等，我必须问一下。
So you've been in this book club five years, and then you won. Yeah. It was neck and neck with another person. Was there any book club drama? Oh, my gosh, yes. So like the first year I played, I almost got first place because I was just like, oh, this is awesome and I'm reading a whole lot.
所以你在这个读书俱乐部待了五年，然后你赢了。是的。跟另一个人不相上下。有什么读书俱乐部狗血剧吗？哦，天哪，有啊。我玩的第一年，我差点得了第一名，因为当时我就想，哦，这太棒了，我在读超多书。
But then someone who was in second like beat me in the last minute. So this year I like hung back in second place. On purpose, like strategy? Yeah, on purpose, because you can kind of see the other people and what they're reading. So I was like clocking what she was reading
但后来一个得第二名的人在最后一分钟超过了我。所以今年我故意保持在第二名。你是故意的，像是什么策略？是的，是故意的，因为你可以大致看到其他人都在读什么。所以我一直在关注她在读什么，
and I was like, oh, I've read way more foreign authors, so I'm going to get like a bonus and win. And then like three days before the deadline, she all of a sudden uploaded seven books. Everyone got really mad because they're like, you can't do that. You can't like hide what you're reading. You have to like have it out in the open. And then I like got on a call with the guy who runs
然后我想，哦，我读的外国作家多得多，所以我会得到一个加分并获胜。然后在截止日期前三天，她突然上传了七本书。每个人都非常生气，因为他们觉得，你不能这么做。你不能隐藏你在读什么。你必须把它摆在明面上。然后我给负责管理的人打了个电话，
it. And he's like, I'm so sorry about this. I'm like, it's okay. I think I can still win. I think if I just listen to audiobooks for two days straight and do puzzles, I can still win. And that's exactly what I did and I won. You were determined. Cause I knew what it felt like to be in first place and lose at the end that I was like, this is driving me insane. If I don't win this year, I don't think I'll ever be able to do it again.
他说，对于这件事我感到非常抱歉。我说，没关系。我想我还是能赢。我想如果我连续两天只听有声书并做拼图，我还是能赢。事实也的确如此，我赢了。你太有决心了。因为我知道得第一名却在最后输掉是什么滋味，所以我想，这简直要把我逼疯了。如果我今年再赢不了，我想我以后再也做不到了。
This year I'm probably only gonna read 10 books. And you got that trophy. I just gave you a thousand page Stephen King books. That's going to take some time if you decide to dive in. I will, I will. I'm reading something else right now, but I will have it on my shelf. Wow.
今年我可能只读10本书。你拿到了那个奖杯。我刚刚给了你一本一千页的斯蒂芬·金的书。如果你决定开始读，那可得花点时间。我会的，我会读的。我现在正在读别的书，但它会摆在我的书架上。哇。
See, every book club has some drama. Well, speaking of book club drama and other club drama, thanks to the assistant editor for the office, Rob Burnett, we have some of the early outlines for the finer things club. You told me you found these. I did not know about these, so this is going to be a surprise to me. These are just a few little fun nuggets. So the writers had this idea to show a few previous finer things club meetings. And this is what it said in the outline. Oh. We see flashbacks of past meetings.
看吧，每个读书俱乐部都有些狗血剧情。说到读书俱乐部狗血剧和其他俱乐部狗血剧，多亏了《办公室》的助理剪辑师罗布·伯内特，我们拿到了一些精致生活俱乐部的早期大纲。你告诉我你发现了这些。我之前不知道这些，所以这对我来说将是一个惊喜。这些只是一些有趣的小爆料。所以编剧们当时有个想法，就是展示一些以前的精致生活俱乐部会议。大纲里是这么写的。哦。我们看到了过去会议的闪回。
Michael tries to join, Meredith comes in and loudly slurps from her cup. Pam says they occasionally have guest lecturers. And they see Darryl playing the entertainer for the Jazz Age meeting. We see Dwight smashing something in the finer things meeting out of frustration. Wow.
迈克尔试图加入，梅雷迪思走进来，大声地从杯子里吸着饮料。帕姆说他们偶尔会有客座讲师。在爵士时代会议上，他们看到达里尔在弹奏《艺人》。我们看到德怀特在精致生活会议上由于沮丧而砸碎了什么东西。哇。
So the finer things club had a lot of people come and go. They ultimately didn't settle on any of that other than Pam, Oscar and Toby and Andy. But there was possibly some back history to the club. Yeah, I like to wonder how long has this been going on? Yeah. And I'm sure to Toby's delight that he gets to have these meetings with Pam.
所以精致生活俱乐部有很多人的来来去去。他们最终没有采纳除帕姆、奥斯卡、托比和安迪之外的任何人。但俱乐部可能有一些过去的背景故事。是的，我想知道这个已经持续多久了？是的。而且我相信托比很高兴能和帕姆一起开这些会。
Oh yeah. Right? But they did sort of toy with like how many other office members have at one point been in the club. And we didn't get to see those play out, but I wish we would have. This is a runner I would have liked to see more of.
哦，是的。对吧？但他们确实稍微玩味了其他办公室成员在某个时候加入过这个俱乐部的设定。我们没能看到那些情节上演，但我希望我们能看到。这是我希望看到更多的日常小桥段。
I am so sad that we did not revisit the finer things club in the way that we would revisit the party planning committee. Yeah. Just somewhere in season nine, if we could have had another meeting, it would have just made me so happy. Well, Angela, when we broke down Branch Wars, you also said that there were some fun deleted scenes
我太遗憾我们没有以回顾派对策划委员会那种方式来回顾精致生活俱乐部了。是的。只要在第九季的某个地方，如果我们能再开一次会，这就会让我超级高兴。好吧，安吉拉，当我们剖析《分公司大战》时，你也说过有一些关于邓德米夫林员工对精致生活俱乐部反应的有趣被删减场景。我们当时没放，但我想既然今天的节目是献给精致生活俱乐部的，我们今天应该放一下。哦，当然。而且它们超级有趣。它们在超级粉丝版里。
about some of the Dunder Mifflin employees' reactions to the finer things club. We didn't play them, but I think that since today's episode is dedicated to the finer things club, we should play them today. Oh, for sure. And they're super fun. They're in the super fan version.
我想从一个本该在这一集开头发生的场景开始。帕姆走向奥斯卡，问他有没有为他们当天的会议带他的书《看得见风景的房间》。安吉拉和凯文太刻薄了。奥斯卡，你带了吗？去他的多尔博恩，他最好的作品。好吧，我有桌布。别忘了餐具。
And I wanna start with one that would have happened at the very beginning of the episode. Pam is gonna walk over to Oscar and ask if he brought his book, A Room with a View, for their meeting that day. And Angela and Kevin are so snarky. Oscar, did you bring it? To be a Dorbjorn, his best work. Okay, well, I have the tablecloth. Don't forget the flatware.
当然，帕姆。迫不及待了。当然，帕姆花哨俱乐部。一定很棒。看看我。我穿内衣。天哪，其实……不过安吉拉喜欢嘲笑帕姆。一定很棒。好吧，我们将听到更多关于安吉拉对精致生活俱乐部看法的消息。事实上，我们有托比、安吉拉和梅雷迪思的采访片段。我们来听听。我喜欢精致生活俱乐部。
Sure thing, Pam. Can't wait. Sure thing, Pam Frufru Club. Must be nice Look at me. I wear underwear My goodness, but actually but Angela likes Mocks Pam must be nice Well, we're gonna hear more about what Angela thinks of the finer things club. In fact, we have talking heads from Toby, Angela, and Meredith. Let's hear it. I love the finer things club.
我的前妻以前有一个读书俱乐部，我会读他们的书，有时在厨房偷听。精致生活俱乐部没有得到派对策划委员会的批准。流氓俱乐部是危险的。我压制了减肥好友互助小组。他们根本不需要聚在一起。那太恶心了。我不知道为什么我不在精致艺术俱乐部里。
My ex-wife used to have a book club and I would read their book and sometimes listen from the kitchen. The finer things club was not sanctioned by the party planning committee. Renegade clubs are dangerous. I squashed the weight loss buddy support group. They didn't need to gather. It was just gross. I don't know why I'm not in the finer arts club.
这简直是胡扯。你们去打扫干净。是的，所以梅雷迪思就像是从这个大的像7-11 Super Gulp的大杯子里吮吸着饮料。然后她直接把它扔在地上，看着镜头说，你们去打扫干净。梅雷迪思，你这样可真没把自己推销出去，进不了精致生活俱乐部。很明显，这个俱乐部惹恼了很多人。他们绝对不是。我是说，如果梅雷迪思把饮料扔在地上，那可不算。
It's bull crap. You clean it up. Yeah, so Meredith is like just slurping out of this big like 7-Eleven Super Gulp. And then she just throws it on the ground and then she looks at camera and she's like, you clean it up. Not really selling yourself, Meredith, to be in the finer things club. Clearly this club ruffled a lot of feathers. They are definitely not. I mean, not if Meredith is throwing her beverage on the ground.
我懂。我想是时候开始分享一些读书俱乐部的狗血剧了，女士。我们开始吧。我太喜欢卢卡斯·G.来自西雅图的这封信了。它经历了一些意想不到的转折。我完全没想到。好吧，我们浏览了你们发来的信件。是的。其中有一封我抽出来说，珍娜，不要读这个。是的。因为我想在这里读给你听。这就是你抽出来的那封。所以我完全不知道
I know. I think it might be time to start sharing some book club dramas, lady. Let's do it. I just love this letter from Lucas G. in Seattle. It took some twists and turns. I was not expecting. Okay, so we went through the letters you guys sent. Yeah. And there was one that I pulled aside and I said, Jenna, do not read this. Yes. Because I want to read it to you here. This is the one you pulled aside. So I have no idea
卢卡斯写了什么，因为我故意没读。没错。我等不及要听了。好吧，卢卡斯说，我有一个完美的关于我的读书俱乐部消亡的故事，这个俱乐部大约在一年消亡的。消亡？我从没想过一次读书俱乐部的聚会会变成一场绝对的灾难，但我们还是遇到了。
what Lucas wrote in because I purposely didn't read it. Correct. I can't wait to hear. All right. Lucas said, I have the perfect story to tell about the demise of my book club, which happened almost a year ago. Demise? I never thought a book club meeting would turn into an absolute disaster, but here we are.
所以我的小组当时在读《安吉拉·卡列尼娜》（译者注：应为安娜·卡列尼娜），你知道的，那部关于婚外情和背叛的经典小说。很应景，因为在我们讨论开始10分钟后，奥利维娅，我室友杰克的女朋友，通常只负责喝红酒的人，漫不经心地说，说实话，我对安娜一点也不同情。她很清楚自己在干什么。一个完全正常的观点，卢卡斯说，
So my group was reading Anna Karenina, you know, the classic novel about affairs and betrayal. Fitting, because 10 minutes into one of our discussions, Olivia, my roommate, Jake's girlfriend, who would usually go for the wine, casually says, honestly, I don't even feel bad for Anna. She knew exactly what she was doing. Totally normal opinion, Lucas says,
除了她说这话时，眼睛直勾勾地盯着我们的朋友佐伊。佐伊立刻充满防备地反击道，你这话是什么意思？奥利维娅坏笑着说，没什么，只是有些人假装自己很无辜，其实并不然。到了这一点，我甚至不知道发生了什么，但我绝对感觉到了那种紧张气氛。接着，杰克，那个和奥利维娅一样喝了好多酒的人，突然脱口而出，等等，这是在说佐伊和达米安的事吗？谁是达米安？
except she says it while staring directly at our friend Zoe. Zoe, immediately defensive, fires back, what is that supposed to mean? Olivia smirking, says, nothing, just that some people pretend they're innocent when they're not. At this point, I didn't even know what was happening, but I definitely felt the tension. Then Jake, who had been drinking as much wine as Olivia, just blurts out, wait, is this about Zoe and Damien? Who's Damien?
卢卡斯写道，现在达米安，他也是读书俱乐部的成员，因为他和奥利维娅是好朋友，刚才一直在刷手机，好像这事跟他没关一样，突然一脸惊慌地抬起头。佐伊脸色变得煞白，而达米安当时的正牌女友贝瑟尼则转向他，一言不发。卢卡斯说，所有人连呼吸都停了。
Lucas writes, now Damien, who is also in the book club because he was good friends with Olivia, had been scrolling his phone like he wasn't a part of the conversation and suddenly looks up panicked. Zoe goes white and Bethany Damien's actual girlfriend at the time just turns to him completely silent. Lucas says, nobody is breathing.
佐伊先打破了沉默，说道，你们现在是认真的吗？达米安说，我不知道，你们在说什么呢？奥利维娅享受着这分分秒秒，耸了耸肩，再次看着佐伊。哦，没什么，只是有些人不尊重边界。你知道的，就像安娜。哦，天哪。
Zoe breaks first and says, Are you serious right now? Damien says, I don't, what are you guys talking about? Olivia, enjoying every second of this, just shrugs while looking at Zoe again. Oh nothing, just that some people don't respect boundaries. You know, like Anna. Oh my gosh.
然后是终结一切的情节反转，佐伊转向达米安说，你告诉她了？轰，核爆炸。贝瑟尼站起身来，离开了，一句话也没说。佐伊气冲冲地追了出去。达米安就坐在那儿，整个人当场石化。
And then the plot twist that ends everything, Zoe turns to Damien and says, you told her? Boom, nuclear explosion. Bethany stands up and leaves, doesn't say a word. Zoe storms after her. Damien just sits there, fully deceased.
奥利维娅抿了一口酒，很是得意。然后，因为杰克无法让这种时刻在沉默中过去，他只是叹了口气说，奥利维娅抿了一口酒，很是得意。然后，因为杰克无法让这种时刻在沉默中过去，他只是叹了口气说，所以我们还在谈论那本书吗？或者，不，杰克，很显然没有。总之，读书俱乐部完蛋了。贝瑟尼和达米安分手了。
Olivia sips her wine, pleased. And then because Jake cannot let the moment sit in silence, he just sighs and goes, Olivia sips her wine, pleased. And then, because Jake cannot let the moment sit in silence, he just sighs and goes, so are we still talking about the book? Or, no, Jake, clearly not. Anyway, book club is dead. Bethany broke up with Damien.
达米安不再和奥利维娅做朋友，但至少佐伊和达米安现在开始约会了。哦，我很幸运没有被城门失火殃及池鱼，但有一件事是肯定的，再也没有人会去读《安吉拉·卡列尼娜》了。哇。这是一个重口味的读书俱乐部故事。安吉拉，你以前加入过读书俱乐部吗？里面有狗血剧情吗？我的意思是，没有，我从来没被邀请过。
Damien stopped being friends with Olivia, but at least Zoe and Damien are dating now. Oh, I was lucky enough to not catch any strays, but one thing's for sure, nobody's ever reading Anna Karenina again. Wow. That's a spicy book club story. Angela, have you ever been in a book club and did it have drama? I mean, no, I've never been asked.
事情是这样的，我有几个朋友在不同的读书俱乐部里，但我从来没被邀请过，这对我一点打击也没有。真的没有。我的意思是，我一直觉得，当时机成熟时，它自然会发生。说实话，现在因为要照顾所有孩子和课外活动，我根本没有空闲时间。我想，我都不知道什么时候能去参加这个读书俱乐部或者做东。但我确实有一个朋友，她非常生气自己没有加入某个特定的读书俱乐部。
Here's the thing, I have several friends in different book clubs and I've never been invited and it does not bump me at all. It really doesn't. I mean, I just have always thought, well, when the timing's right, it'll happen. And honestly, I don't have any free time right now with like all the kids and extracurricular activities. I'm like, I don't know when I'd be going to this book club or hosting a book club. But I do have a friend that is very miffed that she isn't in this one particular book
每当我们和这群闺蜜聚在一起做别的事情时，只有我和她两个人不在那个读书俱乐部里。但就像，我不在乎。每当我们和这群闺蜜聚在一起做别的事情时，只有我和她两个人不在那个读书俱乐部里。但就像，我不在乎。我不在乎。有时当我们聚在一起时，她们会提起正在读的书，或者谁是东道主，
club. And whenever we get together with this group of gals for other things, it's just me and her that's not in the book club. But like, I don't care. And whenever we get together with this group of gals for other things, it's just me and her that's not in the book club. But like, I don't care. I don't care. And sometimes when we're all together, they will bring up a book they're reading or who hosted
或者她们那天晚上的读书俱乐部持续到了多晚，或者噢天哪，你做的那个无麸质柠檬塔太好吃了，或者是读书俱乐部里的某点八卦，而她简直就像在生闷气。因为那太俗气了。好吧，我很抱歉，这些女人是谁啊，竟然当着两个不在她们俱乐部的人的面，兴高采烈地谈论她们的小俱乐部？我不在乎。就像这个读书俱乐部在我进入这个社交圈之前就已经持续好几年了。不过不管怎样，让我觉得有点好笑的是另一个没加入的女孩。现在，真的，
or how late their book club went that night or oh my gosh, that, you know, whatever, that gluten-free lemon tart you made was so good or what some little tidbit from the book club and she literally is like seething. Well because that's tacky. Well I'm sorry to say who are these women who are like actively talking about their little club in front of two people who aren't in their club? I don't care. It's like this book club has been going for years before I was even in this like circle of people. And but anyway, what kind of tickles me is the other gal that's not in it. Now, just really,
如果有人注意的话，她会做出一些举动，比如当她们谈论自己的俱乐部时，她会说“哦”，或者翻白眼。是的。不管怎样，这让我觉得挺搞笑的。我只想说，不知道，读书俱乐部看起来需要很多维护，比如情感维护。我加入过两个读书俱乐部。结果都以灾难告终。哦，天哪。其中一个，我加入的第一个，我是被邀请进去的，这和你的朋友的情况非常相似，也就是这是一群彼此非常要好的女性朋友，
if anyone's paying attention, she does things like she goes, oh, or she rolls her eyes when they talk about their club. Yes. Anyway, it just kind of cracks me up. And I'm just like, I don't know, book clubs seem like a lot of like maintenance, like emotional maintenance. I've been in two book clubs. They both ended in disaster. Oh my gosh. One of them, the first one I was in, I got invited to and it was a very similar thing as your friend, which is that this was like a group of women that were all really good friends
她们经常一起度假。当时只有我和另外一个女孩没有被邀请去度假。我并不在乎，因为老实说我也不想和她们去度假。但我不认识她们，你知道吗？不过读书俱乐部会议的大部分时间都用来做这些度假计划了。
and they like vacationed together. And there was like me and one other gal who were not invited on the vacations. And I didn't care, because honestly I didn't want to vacation with them. But I didn't know them, you know? But like a good portion of the book club meeting would be taken up with making these plans.
我只是觉得我……我只想谈谈书。没错。我不需要讨论每个人的假期。但我懂，因为这是她们所有人聚在一起的时间，她们可以查看各自的日历，可以一起琢磨今年夏天她们的闺蜜行想去哪里或者其他什么。我觉得出于这个原因它很烦人。
And I just sort of felt like I... I just want to talk about the book. Right. I don't need to talk about everyone's vacation. But I get it, because this is the time they're all together, and they can all look at their calendars, and they can all figure out where they want to go this summer or whatever for their girls' trip. I found it annoying for that reason.
但后来其中一次度假发生了一些狗血的事，最终导致整个读书俱乐部彻底闹掰了。我甚至不知道发生了什么。我和她们不是特别熟。这就像我刚搬到洛杉矶时被邀请进去的，我当时只是需要找点事做。我以为我会结识一些人，
But then some drama happened from one of the vacations and it ended up blowing up the whole book club. I don't even know what happened. I wasn't very good friends with them. This was like when I first moved to LA and I got sort of invited in and I just needed something to do. I thought I was going to meet people,
但后来其中一次度假发生了一些戏剧性的事情，最终导致整个读书俱乐部彻底解散了。我甚至不知道发生了什么。我和他们关系不是很好。那大约是我刚搬到洛杉矶的时候，我算是被邀请加入的，当时我只是需要找点事做。我本以为能结识一些人，
maybe make some friends. It did not work out. Well, the other thing I'm kind of learning by being the person not invited in the book club is that people are so, once they get their book club set, they are not taking any applications. No.
或许能交几个朋友。结果并没有成功。好吧，通过不被邀请参加读书会这件事，我学到另一件事是，人们一旦组成了固定的读书会，就再也不会接受任何新申请了。不接受。
Like, that's it. If you have a successful book club, You don't wanna mess with the chemistry. That's why my feelings aren't hurt. Who knows what I'd bring into it? You know? Also, we got this one letter. Now, this isn't the one that I said, don't read, okay?
就像，就这样。如果你有一个成功的读书会，你不会想去破坏这种化学反应。这就是为什么我的心没有受伤。谁知道我会给它带来什么呢？你知道吗？另外，我们收到了这样一封信。等等，这不是我刚才说“别读”的那封，好吗？
But I was curious about this letter. Do you have to pay dues to be in some book clubs? Is that a thing? Listen to this letter, okay? Okay. It's from Jim in Manchester, United Kingdom. He writes and says, I was in a book club up until 1990 when I was deployed to the Gulf whilst in the army. I wrote to say I had to leave giving reasons! Exclamation point.
但我对这封信很好奇。参加某些读书会必须交会费吗？有这回事吗？听听这封信，好吗？好的。这是来自英国曼彻斯特的吉姆写来的。他写道：直到1990年我参军被调往海湾地区之前，我一直都在一个读书会里。我写信说我不得不离开，并给出了理由！感叹号。
Part of our instructions for deploying on active service was not to take books, etc. Oh, okay. However, the book club then sent me a bill for termination of membership, which eventually reached me in the desert and then continued to do so. I eventually wrote back extremely sarcastically, explaining that I was on the cusp of war with several choice words thrown in. I have never heard from them since. I've never heard of this.
我们被部署到现役部队的部分指示是不要携带书籍等物品。哦，好吧。然而，读书会随后给我寄了一张终止会员资格的账单，账单最终辗转传到了沙漠中的我手里，并且之后一直寄给我。我最终写了一封极其讽刺的信回过去，解释说我正处于战争边缘，还夹杂了好几个精选脏话。自那以后，我再也没有收到他们的任何消息。我从来没听说过这种事。
Cassie, does your book club have dews? No. Isn't that interesting? I mean, just yours is the most sort of like very organized. It sounds like it's nationwide, probably. Yeah, we have people in like Florida, Georgia, and someone's mom just joined. So yeah, it's very casual in that sense. nationwide, probably. Yeah, we have people in like Florida, Georgia, and someone's mom just joined.
卡西，你们读书会有会费吗？没有。这不是很奇妙吗？我是说，只有你们的读书会看起来非常有组织。听起来它可能是在全国范围内招募的。是的，我们在佛罗里达州、佐治亚州等地都有成员，而且最近还有人的妈妈刚加入。所以是的，从这个意义上说非常随性。全国范围内，可能吧。是的，我们在佛罗里达州、佐治亚州等地都有成员，而且最近还有人的妈妈刚加入。
So yeah, it's very casual in that sense. Okay, well, I just had never heard that. Sam, have you ever been in a book club? I'm in a book club right now. Wait, what? It just occurred to me, I don't know why during the weeks of planning, this didn't pop into my head,
所以是的，从这个意义上说非常随性。好吧，我只是以前从没听说过这个。萨姆，你参加过读书会吗？我正加入着一个读书会呢。等等，什么？我刚刚突然想到，不知道为什么在策划的这几个星期里，这件事居然没有浮现在我的脑海里，
but I'm part of a book club called the Banned Book Club. We're reading all the books that were banned from schools this year. We just read Handmaid's Tale, it's by vote. We vote which one and now we're halfway through Fahrenheit 451. Nice. Oh, wow.
但我加入了一个叫做“禁书读书会”（Banned Book Club）的读书会。我们正在阅读今年被学校禁掉的所有书。我们刚刚读了《使女的故事》，这是投票决定的。我们投票选出读哪一本，现在我们正读到《华氏451度》的一半。太棒了。哦，哇。
You can join if you want, email bannedbookclub25 at gmail.com. Did you like Margaret Atwood? I did, yeah, it was great. She's great. Yeah. Yeah. And you don't have to pay dues for that book club. Okay. Completely free. Well, okay. Free book club. Yeah. Banned books is just making me think of the band Mallard that you thought the band, it was a banded Mallard, but you thought the duck had been banned? Yes, I did. I didn't know why.
如果你想加入的话可以来，发邮件到 bannedbookclub25@gmail.com。你喜欢玛格丽特·阿特伍德吗？我喜欢，是的，太棒了。她很棒。是啊。是啊。而且你不需要为那个读书会交会费。好吧。完全免费。好吧。免费的读书会。是啊。禁书让我想起了那个叫“绿头鸭”的乐队，你以为那个乐队——那是一只被禁的绿头鸭，但你以为那只鸭子被禁了？是的，我是这么想的。我当时不知道为什么。
I did a whole deep dive in why this one mallard wasn't allowed anymore. But also how I- It was a typo. I did not question it in any way. You're like, what did he do? I took you at your word. I know.
我深入研究了很久，为什么这只绿头鸭不再被允许存在了。但同时我也—那是个拼写错误。我完全没有对此产生任何怀疑。你当时觉得：它到底干了什么？我当时完全相信了你的话。我知道。
That there was a duck that had managed to get banned from a whole state for bad behavior. Yeah, I know. We didn't question it. I was like, well, he must have done something wrong. All right. Well, let us know. Do you have to pay dues for your book club? I've never heard of that. Lady, why don't we take a break? Because you have a deep dive. I do. And it's so fun on the origin of the afternoon tea. And I have another surprise I have to get ready. I have a surprise.
居然有一只鸭子因为行为不端而成功被整个州禁养了。对啊，我知道。我们当时都没有质疑它。我想，嗯，它一定做了什么坏事。好吧，好吧，让我们知道。你们的读书会需要交会费吗？我从来没听说过这事。女士，我们为什么不休息一下呢？因为你有一个深度挖掘环节。我有。而且关于下午茶起源的内容非常有趣。我还有另一个惊喜要准备。我有一个惊喜。
I've been so excited. We have surprises. I have a surprise. I have three bags I'm going to unpack. I have two bags I have to unpack. Well, you had two bags and some books. Well, let's get to it. All right.
我太兴奋了。我们有惊喜。我有一个惊喜。我有三个袋子要打开。我有两个袋子要打开。好吧，你本来有两个袋子和一些书。好吧，我们开始吧。好吧。
Let's do it. All right, let's do it. At Desjardins Insurance, we know that when you're a building contractor, your company's foundation needs to be strong. That's why our agents go the extra mile to understand your business and provide tailored solutions for all its unique needs. You put your heart into your company, so we put your heart into your company, so we put our heart into making sure it's protected. Get insurance that's really big on care. Find an agent today at Desjardins.com slash business coverage. This episode is brought to you by Dzone.
我们开始吧。好吧，我们开始吧。在嘉铎保险（Desjardins Insurance），我们深知作为一名建筑承包商，贵公司的根基必须坚如磐石。这就是为什么我们的代理商会付出额外努力，深入了解您的业务，并为其所有独特需求提供量身定制的解决方案。您将心血倾注于公司，因此我们倾注全部心力确保其得到妥善保护。选择真正关怀备至的保险。今天就访问 Desjardins.com 查找 business coverage 获取代理商信息。本集由 Dzone 赞助播出。
For the first time ever, the 32 best soccer clubs from across the world are coming together to decide who the undisputed champions of the world are in the FIFA Club World Cup. The world's best players, Messi, Holland, Kane and more are all taking part. And you can watch every match for free on DAZN starting on June 14th and running until July 13th. Sign up now at dazon.com slash FIFA. That That's d-a-z-n dot com slash fifa. No Frills delivers. Get groceries delivered to your door from No Frills with PC Express. Shop online and get $15 in PC optimum points on your first five orders. Shop now at nofrills.ca. at nofrills.ca.
有史以来第一次，来自世界各地的32家顶级足球俱乐部齐聚一堂，在国际足联俱乐部世界杯（FIFA Club World Cup）上决出谁是无可争议的世界冠军。梅西、哈兰德、凯恩等世界顶级球员都将悉数参赛。从6月14日到7月13日，您可以在 DAZN 上免费观看每一场比赛。立即在 dazon.com/fifa 注册。即 d-a-z-n 点 com 斜杠 fifa。No Frills 送货上门。通过 PC Express 从 No Frills 订购杂货并送货到家。现在网购，您的前五笔订单即可获得 15 加元的 PC Optimum 积分。立即在 nofrills.ca 选购。在 nofrills.ca 选购。
Okay, everybody, we are back. I am in studio with my eyes closed because Angela has insisted that I close my eyes because she's gonna surprise me with something and I don't know what it is. Keep them closed. They're closed. I'm not looking, I'm not looking. Do not open your eyes yet.
好了，各位，我们回来了。我闭着眼睛在录音室里，因为安吉拉坚持让我闭上眼睛，因为她要用某种东西给我一个惊喜，但我不知道是什么。闭上眼睛。闭着呢。我没看，我没看。先别睁开眼睛。
Oh, I'm hearing. It sounds like ceramics. Okay, open your eyes. You guys all get an afternoon tea hat. Everyone gets a tea hat with roses from my garden. Jenna, you get black. Oh, thank you. I'm gonna give you this one.
哦，我听到了。听起来像是陶瓷的声音。好了，睁开眼睛吧。你们每人都有一顶下午茶帽。每个人都有一顶带有我花园里的玫瑰花的茶帽。珍娜，你的是黑色的。哦，谢谢你。我要把这个送给你。
Thank you. Samuel, I have the big broad rim. Thank you. Lady. These use this one. Thank you. Samuel, I have the big broad rim. Thank you. Lady. These are flowers from my garden. And look at my teapot. Your teapot is a kitty cat. I know.
谢谢你。塞缪尔，我给你准备了宽边大帽。谢谢你。女士。这些用这个。谢谢你。塞缪尔，我给你准备了宽边大帽。谢谢你。女士。这些是我花园里的玫瑰花。瞧瞧我的茶壶。你的茶壶是只小猫咪。我知道。
I'll tell a whole story about it. Look. Lady, guess what I brought as my surprise. What? I brought tea fascinators for everyone. We have so much headwear today. This is amazing. We have to take a picture. We can do one with hats and one with fascinators.
我待会儿要讲一个关于它的完整故事。看。女士，你猜我作为惊喜带来了什么？什么？我为大家带了茶趣帽（fascinators）。我们今天有好多头饰啊。这太棒了。我们得拍张照片。我们可以拍一张戴帽子的，再拍一张戴茶趣帽的。
Thank you so much, Angela. And with roses from your garden. Yes, I picked the roses this morning and then I bought the hats and I put the roses in the little rim of the hat. Each hat has a band around it, so I tucked the roses in the band. Well, I love a tea party and I have fascinators. I brought in my four fascinators. What is a fascinator?
非常感谢你，安吉拉。而且还有你花园里的玫瑰花。对，我今天早上摘了玫瑰花，然后我买了帽子，把玫瑰花插在帽子的边缘。每顶帽子周围都有一条带子，所以我把玫瑰花塞进带子里了。嗯，我很喜欢茶会，而且我有茶趣帽。我带来了我自己的四顶茶趣帽。什么是茶趣帽？
It is, it's like what they wear to fancy weddings and things in England. Yes, and you can wear them to tea. One of these four fascinators is made by a famous, like very famous, milliner, Evita Petty. Her hats are sold at the oldest hat shop in Uptown, New York. Ooh. But you can also get them online at harlemsheaven.com.
就是，就像他们在英国参加豪华婚礼等场合时戴的那种。是的，你戴着它去喝茶也可以。这四顶茶趣帽中有一顶是由一位著名的，可以说是非常著名的女帽商埃维塔·佩蒂（Evita Petty）制作的。她的帽子在纽约上城最古老的帽店里出售。哦。不过你也可以在 harlemsheaven.com 上网购买。
Well, lady. And I met her. You met her? Yes, ma'am. So I was thinking, actually, maybe before I do my deep dive, maybe we should share what you and I just did on break. Which is hilarious. Because we both surprised each other with tea.
嗯，女士。而且我见过她。你见过她？是的，夫人。所以我在想，其实，也许在我进行深度挖掘之前，我们应该分享一下你和我在休息时刚做的事。那太搞笑啦。因为我们两个人都用茶给对方制造了惊喜。
Yes. So I'm going to share about the origins of the tea party. But one of the things I brought was a little, it's like a tea set. It's a teacup with a plate. But it's a double plate. It is. And it's so special to me.
是的。所以我要分享茶会的起源。但我带来的其中一样东西是一个小物件，有点像一套茶具。这是一个带盘子的茶杯。但它是一个双层盘子。是的。它对我很特殊。
My mom bought this at an antique store like 20 years ago. She gave it to me. And she was like, Angie, it's really old. And it's just been in my china cabinet. I've never used it. And I thought, what a better day. I looked on the back. It says Made in England TF&S LTD. So I looked used it. And I thought, what a better day. I looked on the back, it says Made in England,
我妈妈大约20年前在古董店买下了这个。她把它送给了我。她当时说：“安吉，这真的很老旧。”它一直放在我的瓷器柜里。我从来没用过它。我想，还有什么日子比今天更合适呢。我看了看背面。上面写着“英国制造 TF&S 有限公司”。所以我看了用过它。我想，还有什么日子比今天更合适呢。我看了看背面，上面写着“英国制造”，
TF&S, LTD. So I looked that up. I was very curious, what does that mean? And you guys out there that are antique collectors, you can let me know. But what I found is that Thomas Forster originally started a pottery business on Longton High Street. It was a small workshop in 1877.
TF&S 有限公司。所以我查了一下。我很好奇，那是什么意思？你们这些古董收藏家可以在外面告诉我。但我发现的是，托马斯·福斯特（Thomas Forster）最初是在朗顿高街（Longton High Street）经营陶瓷生意的。1877年时它只是一个小作坊。
And Thomas's sons, Herbert and Victor, were introduced to the business and became partners. And so the company name became Thomas Forster and Sons LTD in 1891. Wow. So I'm not sure when these were made, but I guess. I mean, chances are a hundred years ago, it sounds like. And it says, over the next 10 years, their company really grew, and it was one of the largest employers in Staffordshire at the end of the Queen Victoria reign in 1901. Well, they're really lovely.
托马斯的儿子赫伯特（Herbert）和维克托（Victor）随后加入了这项业务并成为了合伙人。因此，公司名称在1891年变更为“托马斯福斯特父子公司有限责任公司”（Thomas Forster and Sons LTD）。哇。所以我不太确定这些是什么时候制作的，不过我猜。我是说，听起来很有可能是一百年前的东西。上面写着，在随后的10年里，他们的公司真正成长起来了，并且在1901年维多利亚女王统治结束时，它是斯塔福德郡（Staffordshire）最大的雇主之一。嗯，它们真的很可爱。
I sort of described them as like a double plate, but what it is, it's like, imagine if you have your tea cup and saucer, but then the saucer is part of a plate. So you have a little spot for your tea sandwiches and also a spot for your teacup, and it is absolutely dainty and wonderful. Well, one of the reasons I was so excited to bring them in when I found out sort of the time when this company
我有点把它描述为双层盘子，但实际情况是，想象一下如果你有茶杯和茶托，但这个茶托本身就是盘子的一部分。所以你有一个放茶三明治的小地方，还有一个放茶杯的地方，它绝对是小巧精致又美妙。嗯，当我发现这家公司成立的大致时间时，我之所以这么兴奋地想把它带来，
was formed is because of my deep dive, which was all about high tea, because as you know, the finer things club was not just books. It also included food. It also included works of art. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. So first of all, did you know that every year
是因为我的深度挖掘，内容全关于下午茶，因为正如你们所知，精致生活俱乐部（finer things club）不单单只有书籍。它还包括食物。它还包括艺术品。嗯——哼。嗯——哼。所以首先，你知道吗？每年
there is a celebration of the afternoon tea and it's for a whole week? What week is it and why am I not celebrating it? It's called afternoon tea week and it takes place every second full week in August. This year is going to be August 11th to the 17th and there are even discounts for afternoon tea during that week at different places. Oh my gosh, I've never been so excited to find out a piece of news. So here is my deep dive on the afternoon tea. When did it become popular?
都会有一个庆祝下午茶的节日，而且持续整整一周？那是哪一周，为什么我没有在庆祝它？它被称为“下午茶周”（afternoon tea week），在每年八月的第二个完整周举行。今年将是8月11日至17日，在那一周里，不同地方甚至还有下午茶折扣。哦天哪，我从来没有因为听到一条新闻而这么兴奋过。所以这是我关于下午茶的深度挖掘。它是什么时候流行起来的？
Who made become popular? Who made it popular? Well, according to the internet, Portugal was probably most responsible. In 1662, when Charles II married a member of the Portuguese royal family, Catherine of Braganza, she brought tea with her as part of her dowry. And tea soon became the official court beverage in the 1660s. At that time, tea was scarce, expensive, and highly taxed. It was a rare luxury that only the upper class could afford.
谁让它流行起来的？谁让它流行起来的？好吧，根据互联网的说法，葡萄牙可能是最主要的推手。1662年，查理二世娶了葡萄牙王室成员凯瑟琳·德·布拉干萨（Catherine of Braganza）为妻，她把茶作为嫁妆的一部分带了过来。在17世纪60年代，茶很快成为了官方的宫廷饮品。当时，茶很稀缺、昂贵且税收极高。这是一种只有上流阶层才能负担得起的罕见奢侈品。
Now we're gonna jump in time, okay? So you got the tea part. When did the snacks come, Jenna? That's what I wanna know. The snacks are my favorite part. I don't even really like tea. Oh, well, I love the tea part, so I wanted all of it. Yes, when I go to tea, sometimes I request coffee.
现在我们要时光倒流了，好吧？所以你了解了茶的部分。茶点是什么时候出现的，珍娜？这正是我想知道的。茶点是我最喜欢的部分。我其实甚至不太喜欢茶。哦，好吧，我很喜欢茶的部分，所以我想要全部。是的，我去喝茶时，有时会要求喝咖啡。
Oh, well, don't tell anyone. Can I please just get a picture of Sam with his hat on? Please, just sitting there, sound mixing, and helping us out. Someone, Cassie, will you take a picture? Thank you. I just looked up and I saw Sam in his white hat with pink roses. From my eyeline, I can see Cassie and she is also wearing her hat. She is sitting there producing our podcast.
哦，好吧，千万别告诉任何人。我能拍一张萨姆戴着帽子的照片吗？求你了，就坐在那儿混音，帮我们一把。卡西，谁来拍张照？谢谢。我刚刚抬头看见萨姆戴着一顶带粉红玫瑰的白帽子。从我的视线看过去，我能看到卡西，她也戴着帽子。她正坐在那儿制作我们的播客。
Sam, will you please take a picture of Cassie? Wearing her hat. Okay. All right. So now we figured out the tea element. Well, let's talk about the snacks part. Cut to around 1840. According to the internet, it's because of urbanization and the rise of industrialization in England that the evening meal was becoming later and later. It was cut. Because people were working later.
萨姆，请你给卡西拍张照片好吗？戴着帽子的那种。好的。好吧，现在我们搞清楚了茶的元素。好吧，我们来谈谈茶点部分。镜头快进到1840年左右。根据互联网的说法，由于英国的城市化和工业化进程，晚餐的时间变得越来越晚。它被切断了。因为人们工作到很晚。
Yes. It was customary for the upper classes in England to have their evening meal around 8 p.m. Well, Anna Maria Russell, the seventh Duchess of Bedford, was not having it. She complained of a sinking feeling and requested that some light food and a pot of tea, usually Darjeeling, which is the tea I brought today. Okay. She requested that this be brought to her private living quarters to help ward off that mid-afternoon hunger. She was hangry. She was hangry.
是的。英国上流阶层习惯在晚上8点左右吃晚餐。嗯，贝德福德公爵夫人安娜·玛丽亚·罗素（Anna Maria Russell, the seventh Duchess of Bedford）可不买账。她抱怨有一种下坠感，并要求送一些清淡的食物和一壶茶——通常是大吉岭红茶，也就是我今天带来的茶。好吧。她要求把这些送到她的私人起居室里，以帮助驱散那下午中段的饥饿感。她当时饿怒交加。她当时饿怒交加。
She requested some tea, bread, butter, and cake be brought to her room. Well, this idea proved so successful that it soon became routine, and the Duchess decided to invite a few of her friends to her private rooms for tea. And now this new social event was born because the guests would have an opportunity to meet, catch up, chitty-chat, discuss recent events. The service would normally take place in the ladies' parlor or drawing room and be served on low decorative tables. Hence, this event became known as Low Tea.
她要求把一些茶、面包、黄油和蛋糕送到她的房间里。嗯，这个想法证明非常成功，很快就成为了惯例，公爵夫人决定邀请她的几位朋友去她的私人房间喝茶。现在，这个新的社交活动诞生了，因为客人们将有机会见面、叙旧、闲聊、讨论最近发生的事件。服务通常在女士的沙龙或客厅举行，并摆在矮小的装饰桌上。因此，这个活动被称为“矮茶”（Low Tea）。
Low Tea? Oh, honey, you wait. I knew you would ask. I knew. Wait for it. But the Duchess of Bedford was one of Queen Victoria's ladies-in-waiting. Specifically, she was her Lady of the Bedchamber. Her duties included assisting with dressing, bathing, other personal care, as well as accompanying
矮茶？哦，亲爱的，你等着。我就知道你会问。我早就知道了。拭目以待吧。但贝德福德公爵夫人是维多利亚女王的女侍臣之一。具体来说，她是她的寝室女官。她的职责包括协助穿衣、洗澡、其他个人护理，以及陪同
her to public events and receptions. They were lifelong friends, and she introduced Queen Victoria to the idea, and the trend gained popularity, and soon became a fashionable pastime of the upper class. And to meet this new demand, English china manufacturers, linen makers, and silversmiths began turning out fine accoutrements to be served in the service of afternoon tea. Jenna, might my plate and teacup have been made during this age? I think so! It sounds like it!
她出席公众活动和招待会。她们是终身挚友，她把这个想法介绍给了维多利亚女王，这种潮流风靡开来，很快成为上流阶层一种时尚的消遣方式。为了满足这一新需求，英国的瓷器制造商、亚麻布制造商和银匠开始大量生产用于下午茶服务的精美配套器具。珍娜，我的盘子和茶杯会不会是在这个时代制作的？我想是的！听起来是这样的！
I'm very excited at this. This so-called at-home tea spread throughout England, where announcements would be sent to friends and relatives, declaring the hour at which tea would be served. But there is some controversy, because as we know, with the finer things club, there is always drama. What is it? According to a website called the English Manor, this was written, Whilst we do know that Anna Russell did serve tea in the afternoon, five o'clock tea as
我对这个感到非常兴奋。这种所谓的“在家下午茶”在全英国传开，人们会向亲朋好友发送通知，声明供应茶水的时间。但其中存在一些争议，因为正如我们所知，精致生活俱乐部里总少不了抓马。那是什么？根据一个名为“英国庄园”（The English Manor）的网站上的一篇文章写道：
she referred to it, this isn't unusual for aristocratic ladies of that and earlier eras. If the Duchess of Bedford did invent afternoon tea, why did Victoria, when staying with Queen Elizabeth of Prussia right in her journal on the 15th of August 1845, saying this, Quote, We went down to what is called the Painted Room and had tea, quite in the German way. We princesses sat down to a table on which there was no cloth and excellent cakes of all kinds were served whilst the queens ladies made the tea."
“虽然我们确实知道安娜·罗素确实在下午供应茶水，也就是她所说的下午五点茶，但这对于那个时代及更早时代的贵族女士来说并不罕见。如果贝德福德公爵夫人真的发明了下午茶，为什么维多利亚女王在1845年8月15日访问普鲁士的伊丽莎白女王时，会在日记中写下这样的话？
Oh, oh, so what are they saying? That maybe this was happening already? But it is very clear to me on many sites that the Duchess of Bedford was the one that was the squeaky wheel. Like, let's make this happen. Yeah. And you might be asking yourself,
引述如下：‘我们下楼来到所谓的彩绘室喝茶，完全是德国风格。我们几位公主坐到一张没有桌布的桌子旁，上面摆满了各种极好的蛋糕，而女王的女官们则负责泡茶。’”哦，哦，所以他们是在说什么？这可能以前就已经在发生了？但在许多网站上，我很清楚地看到，贝德福德公爵夫人才是那个爱叫的轮子。就像，让我们把这事办成吧。是啊。你可能在问自己，
why don't we call it low tea? Why don't we? I was asking myself that. It's called high tea. Well, for working class men and women, during and after the two world wars, when they would finally have time to eat around 5 p.m. and onwards, they were really hungry, and they naturally
为什么我们不叫它“矮茶”？为什么不呢？我刚才就在问自己这个问题。这叫“高茶”（high tea）。好吧，对于工薪阶层的男女来说，在两次世界大战期间及之后，当他们终于有时间在下午5点左右及以后用餐时，他们真的很饿，自然而然地
felt the need to eat something more filling than just sandwiches and cake and their much-awaited pot of tea. That's when we started to see the addition of the word, high. The phrase high tea started to be used to describe a working class meal served at a high table with a high back dining chair at the end of a long workday. The tea would be accompanied by a hot meal. Oh! So high tea had nothing to do with the elite social gathering that started back in the 19th century with the Duchess of Bedford. High tea sounds like it had some, like, hot foods. High tea was a bigger meal.
觉得需要吃点比三明治、蛋糕和他们翘首以盼的一壶茶更顶饱的东西。那就是我们开始看到加入“高”这个词的时候。高茶这个词开始被用来描述工薪阶层的餐食，在一天的漫长工作结束时，在高桌子和高靠背的餐椅上供应。茶会伴随着一顿热食。哦！所以高茶与19世纪由贝德福德公爵夫人开始的精英社交聚会毫无关系。高茶听起来像是有一些热食。高茶是一顿更丰盛的餐。
Okay. More things. Well, I'll have you know, lady, I worked for eight months over in London and tea is a thing. Yes. On the television set that I worked on at 3 p.m., a person would come out pushing a cart full of tea and cakes.
好吧。更多的东西。嗯，我得让你知道，女士，我在伦敦那边工作了八个月，喝茶在那里是一件大事。是的。在我工作的电视片场，下午3点钟，会有人推着一车茶和蛋糕出来。
Yes. Like little packages of cakes and you would grab a cup and you would get some tea and you would take a little cake right around three o'clock every single day. I thought I was like, really? This is so lovely. I had no idea. It's so lovely.
是的。就像一小包一小包的蛋糕，你可以拿个杯子，倒点茶，每天下午三点整准时拿一小块蛋糕。我当时觉得：真的吗？这太美妙了。我根本不知道。这太美妙了。
It was a thing. I did a semester abroad in London and at the college I was at, we would take tea. Yeah, with the faculty, the students and faculty. I loved it. I also lady brought my little tea kitty cat. When you pour it, it's a cat, when you pour it the tea comes out of his little paw that's up in the air. It's really the cutest little thing. It's white, and it is covered in little purple flowers. It's so dainty and lovely. Guess where I got it.
这真是一回事。我在伦敦参加了一个学期海外交流，在我所在的学院里，我们会喝下午茶。是的，和教职员工、学生和教职员工一起。我很喜欢。女士，我还带来了我的小猫咪茶壶。你倒茶的时候它是一只猫，倒茶时茶水从它高高举起的小爪子里流出来。真的是最可爱的小东西。它是白色的，上面长满了紫色的小花。它既小巧又可爱。你猜我在哪儿弄到的。
Where? I bid on it at the Furball at the Skirball charity event that I went to when you hosted. Oh, that's right. And I won it. And today, I made Queen Elizabeth II's cucumber sandwiches. Did you know that she put her own spin
在哪儿？我在你主持的Skirball慈善活动“Furball”上竞拍买下的。哦，对了。我拍中了。今天，我做了伊丽莎白女王二世的黄瓜三明治。你知道她对经典三明治进行了
on the classic sandwich? What did she do to it? She added mint to it. Mint? Yes. So I brought that, and I brought my little plates and tea, hats and hats. And I also have a website to share with everyone. It's a blog called A Lady in London,
自己的改良吗？她往里面加了什么？她往里面加了薄荷。薄荷？是的。所以我带了这个，我还带了自己的小盘子、茶帽和帽子。我还有一个网站要分享给大家。这是一个名为“A Lady in London”的博客，
and she goes over all the best places to have afternoon tea in London. I'm feeling very excited about what you brought. I saw you putting some stuff together you have to share. Well, you know I love a tea. I just love it. I know. And now that I can eat gluten again, it's like the first thing I wanted.
上面盘点了伦敦所有喝下午茶的最佳去处。我对你带来的东西感到非常兴奋。我看到你一直在把一些东西拼起来，你得分享一下。好吧，你知道我有多爱茶。我就是爱。我知道。既然我现在又能吃麸质了，这就成了我最想做的事。
I was like, give me all the bread and the scones and all the things. So I brought a full tea service. I know you guys, Jenna. All of the sandwiches, the scones. Where did you order it from? It's from a little spot called Sugar Bird Cafe in Los Angeles. So they have two locations.
我当时就想：把所有的面包、司康饼和所有好吃的都给我端上来。所以我带来了一整套茶具。我知道你们懂的，珍娜。所有的三明治、司康饼。你是从哪儿订的？来自洛杉矶一个叫“糖鸟咖啡馆”（Sugar Bird Cafe）的小地方。他们有两个分店。
So if you're in LA, you can look them up. We have the cucumber sandwiches I made, but then what all came with yours? They're little finger sandwiches. And Cassie, I made sure to let them know that we had a vegetarian in our group. Yay. And scones and then little sweet treats.
所以如果你在洛杉矶，你可以去搜一下。我们有我做的黄瓜三明治，但你带的里面都有些什么？都是些手指三明治（finger sandwiches）。卡西，我有特别交代他们我们团队里有素食主义者。太好了。还有司康饼以及小甜点。
Well, lady, we set it all up. I know. We should go have tea. Let's have tea. So we're gonna do a fakie brakie. We're not really going anywhere as far as y'all are concerned. We don't wanna eat on the mic basically, you guys.
好吧，女士，我们全都布置好了。我知道。我们该去喝茶了。我们喝茶去吧。所以我们要来个“假休息”（fakie brakie）。据你们所知，我们其实哪儿也没去。基本上，各位，我们不想在麦克风前吃东西。
We're trying to respect your wishes. So we'll be right back. We're gonna tell you how it was. I'm gonna put my hat on. Ah, I can't wait. Well, we just had low tea. We were at a low table. We had low tea and I'm still eating
我们在努力尊重大家的愿望。所以我们马上回来。我们会告诉你们感觉如何。我要把帽子戴上。啊，我等不及了。好吧，我们刚喝了矮茶。我们坐在一张矮桌子旁。我们喝了矮茶，我现在还在吃
one of the shortbread cookies from the tea. It was so delicious. Even though we said we wouldn't eat anymore on mic. It was so delicious and so fun. And we sat there with our hats and our fascinators. You and Cassie were the fascinators, me and Sam wore the hats. We had a delicious tea.
茶点里的那种酥饼。太好吃了。尽管我们说过不在麦克风前吃东西了。真的太好美味又太好玩了。我们戴着帽子和茶趣帽坐在那里。你和卡西戴的是茶趣帽，我和萨姆戴的是帽子。我们喝了一顿美味的下午茶。
And what do we think you guys? Did you like Queen Elizabeth the's version of the cucumber sandwich or the other version that was from the tea house? I like the one you brought. Queen Elizabeth II. I did too. And I was asking you what the difference was because the ones we got from the tea house were like a cream cheese and cucumber sandwich, which I've had many times. But yours, I said, had a little bit of like a salty. Okay, so here are the ingredients
大家觉得怎么样呢？你们是喜欢伊丽莎白女王二世版的黄瓜三明治，还是茶室的那种版本？我喜欢你带的那种。伊丽莎白女王二世版的。我也是。我刚才问你有什么区别，因为我们从茶室买的是奶油乳酪黄瓜三明治，我已经吃过很多次了。但你带的这个，我说过，带有一点点那种咸味。好吧，那么以下是
for Queen Elizabeth II's cucumber sandwich. On the website I saw, it said, the royal recipe is said to contain a simple combination of just five ingredients, bread, butter, sliced cucumber, a dash of mint, and a sprinkle of salt and black pepper. And the one thing I didn't do was I didn't put black pepper because I didn't know.
伊丽莎白女王二世的黄瓜三明治的配料。我在网站上看到的说，皇室食谱据说只包含简单的五种配料组合：面包、黄油、黄瓜片、少许薄荷、以及撒上的盐和黑胡椒。我唯一没做的是我没有放黑胡椒，因为我不知道。
Some people are like, eh, I don't want anything peppery. I thought they were amazing. I loved them. Well, there you go. Well, now that we've had some tea, should I spill some tea? Spill it. Should I tell my big book club drama story? Yes, I can't wait.
有些人会觉得：呃，我不要任何带胡椒味的。我觉得它们太棒了。我很喜欢。好吧，就是这样。好了，既然我们已经喝过茶了，我是不是该爆点料了？爆料吧。我要不要讲讲我那个大型读书会抓马故事？好啊，我等不及了。
Okay. This is a little bit of a Los Angeles book club story in the sense that, you know, Los Angeles is very spread out. Oh yeah. Like for us, traffic dictates everything. Like my sisters just visited and back in Texas, they watch the Weather Channel.
好吧。这是一个有点洛杉矶特色的读书会故事，因为你知道的，洛杉矶非常广阔。哦，是的。对我们来说，交通决定了一切。比如我的姐姐们刚来访问，在德克萨斯州老家，他们会看天气频道。
They're always checking in with the Weather Channel, but here for us, it's traffic. It's traffic and there's a sort of thing where you're like do you live on the east side? Do you live on the west side? Do you live in the valley? So at this time I lived in the valley. Uh oh. And I had a good friend who lived in the valley and one of our mutual friends lived on the west side. Mm-hmm. And I thought you were going to say that. You might as well live in Arizona.
他们总是查看天气频道，但对我们来说，是交通。是交通，而且有一种情况，你会想：你住在东区吗？你住在西区吗？你住在山谷区（the valley）吗？所以当时我住在山谷区。噢，不。我有一个好朋友住在山谷区，我们共同的一个朋友住在西区。嗯——哼。我以为你要这么说。你干脆住在亚利桑那州得了。
You might as well. But we loved her. She started a book club. Now she started a book club with all of her friends on the west side. And then me and my friend who lived in the valley. There were 12 ladies. Okay. And then me and my friend who lived in the valley. There were 12 ladies. And this was going to be perfect because there are 12 months of the year.
你干脆住那得了。但我们很爱她。她发起了一个读书会。她和西区的所有朋友一起发起了一个读书会。然后我和住在山谷区的朋友也加入了。一共有12位女士。好吧。然后我和住在山谷区的朋友也加入了。一共有12位女士。这太完美了，因为一年有12个月。
And once a month we would meet. And whoever hosted the book club got to pick the book and then they would also provide the food. Which, of course, if you were were being fun you would try to tie it into the book. Oh, very finer things club. Very finer things club. So it was going great. There must have been like six, eight meetings all on the west side. So me and my friend in the valley, it would take us almost an hour each way. Oh yeah.
我们每个月聚会一次。轮到谁主办读书会，谁就来选书，并且还要提供食物。当然，如果你觉得好玩的话，你会尽量让食物和书本联系起来。哦，非常有精致生活俱乐部的风格。非常有精致生活俱乐部的风格。所以一切进展顺利。大概已经有过六、八次聚会了，全都在西区。所以我和山谷区的朋友，单程就要花将近一个小时。哦，是的。
But we did it because we really liked these ladies, we liked this book club, and we would carpool. So we kind of got some extra friend time in the car. Lady, when it was finally time for my valley friend to host, she picked the book, everybody great. When it came time for the meeting, one of the West Side ladies said, "'Hey, the valley is really far for me.
但我们还是去了，因为我们真的很喜欢这些女士，我们喜欢这个读书会，而且我们会拼车。所以我们在车里还能多享受一点朋友相处的时光。女士，终于轮到我的山谷区朋友主办时，她选了本书，大家都觉得很棒。到了聚会的时候，其中一位西区的女士说：“嘿，山谷区对我和说太远了。
How about I host at my house because it's gonna be closer for everyone.'" Excuse me, what about the two of us that drive an hour every month? For eight months, we have been driving to the book club on the West Side. And in the car, as we would sit in traffic for this two-hour round-trip adventure, we would just say, you know what?
不如我在我家主办吧，因为对大家来说更近一些。”不好意思，那我们这两个每个月开车一小时的人算什么？八个月来，我们一直都在开车去西区的读书会。在车里，当我们在这趟两小时往返的冒险中陷入交通堵塞时，我们总是会说：你知道吗？
Two months out of the year. We get it. We will not have to do the driving. So what happened? Did they say? Oh. Like, what did you say? You have to be like, it's our turn. It's our turn. She said, I was really looking forward to hosting.
一年就两个月。我们认了。我们不用开车了。结果怎么着？他们说了什么？哦。比如，你当时说了什么？你肯定得说：轮到我们了。轮到我们了。她说：我真的很期待主办。
I've planned the menu. I've bought the food. Because this suggestion of changing the location of the book club came in, like, the day before the book club was happening. When she realized it wasn't on the West Side. Yes. So my friend said, no, I was really looking forward to hosting. I've planned the menu. It's going to be at my house. What happened? Like half the people didn't come.
我都计划好菜单了。食物我都买好了。因为这个更改读书会地点的建议，是在读书会开始前一天左右提出来的。当她发现聚会不在西区时。是的。所以我的朋友说：不行，我真的很期待主办。我连菜单都计划好了。就在我家办。结果怎么样？大概有一半人没来。
Wow. They didn't drive. So like six of you are just talking about this book and the other six are just like, we're not driving there. Yeah. They said we're really sorry, but it was just, it's too much of a trek. What do they think you'd been doing? Exactly.
哇。她们没有开车过来。所以你们大概有六个人在讨论这本书，而另外六个人就觉得：我们才不往那儿开呢。对啊。她们说：我们真的很抱歉，但这实在太远了，太折腾了。她们以为你们平时都在干嘛？没错。
Exactly, lady. Nope. Nope. We quit. You quit? Me and my valley friend. Did you start a valley book club? We didn't.
没错，女士。才不呢。不干了。我们退出了。你们退出了？我和我的山谷区朋友。你们自己搞了个山谷区读书会吗？没有。
We just were like, you know what? We're done. It was too much. It was such a slap in the face. Yeah. Yeah. I was gonna say, are you still friends with that group? You know, no, none of,
我们只是觉得：你知道吗？我们受够了。太过了。这简直是当众打脸。啊哈。是的。我本来想问，你还和那个群体保持朋友关系吗？你知道的，没有，
I'm still friends with the gal from the West side. She's actually moved away, so I don't see her very much. But I'm kept in touch with zero of the other ladies. Here's the thing. As you know, I have never been invited to be in a book club. But I am just seeing now all the shit comes out at book club. Yeah. I had no idea.
我和西区的那位姑娘还是朋友。她实际上已经搬走了，所以我不太常常见到她。但我跟其他所有女士都彻底断了联系。事情是这样的。如你所知，我从来没有被邀请加入过读书会。但我现在才发现，所有的破事全都在读书会里暴露出来了。是啊。我完全不知道。
I knew there was drama-ish, but I had no idea it was this amount. Speaking of book club drama, can I please share the letter I told you not to read now? Yes. Okay. This letter is from Daphne B. in Montana. Daphne wrote in and said, "'I am part of a book club that has a main group of girls
我知道里面有点抓马，但我完全没想到会是这种程度。说到读书会的抓马，我现在可以分享那封你刚才叫我不要读的信了吗？可以。好的。这封信来自蒙大拿州的达芙妮·B（Daphne B.）。达芙妮写信说：“我参加了一个读书会，里面有一个核心女孩群体，
and then some other ladies. It's usually like 15-ish girls, and every month 10 to 12 show up, and it's a super great time and a fun way to get some girl time. Well, one of the main girls texted our big chat that she wasn't going to be part of the book club anymore, which shocked me, shocked in all caps.
还有一些其他女士。通常大概有15个左右的女孩，每个月会有10到12个人露面，这度过了一段超级棒的时光，也是和闺蜜们聚会的一种有趣方式。嗯，其中一个核心女孩在我们的群聊里发信息说她不再参加读书会了，这震惊了我，‘震惊’全是大写。
So I knew something was wrong. At the next book club, I got the tea. Apparently, the girl that left the club, let's call her Lucy. You know we love it when we have to have a code name. Please give us all the code names. Okay, so apparently the girl that left the club, let's call her Lucy, was because all the other main group of friends had confronted her as an entire group
所以我知道出事了。在下一次读书会上，我吃到了这个瓜。显然，那个离开俱乐部的女孩——我们暂且叫她露西吧。你知道我们最喜欢需要用代号的时候了。请把所有的代号都告诉我们。好吧，显然离开俱乐部的那个女孩（我们叫她露西）之所以离开，是因为其他核心朋友圈的成员作为整个集体找她对质了，
because Lucy and her husband and another girl from the book club that is also not a part of the main friend group, let's call her Hannah. Okay. They all got it on. Wait, Hannah, Lucy, and Lucy's husband had a threesome. Yes.
因为露西和她的丈夫，还有读书会里另一个不属于核心朋友圈的女孩——我们叫她汉娜吧。好吧。他们全搞到一起去了。等等，汉娜、露西和露西的丈夫搞了个三人行。是的。
But Hannah and Lucy are in the book club together. They were. She goes on to say, Hannah had already left the group. And then in parentheses, she said, she only ever came to a few book clubs. But Lucy was confronted about her husband being the worst and how she should leave him.
但汉娜和露西一起在这个读书会里。她们曾经是。她接着说：汉娜已经离开这个群体了。然后她在括号里说：她总共只来过几次读书会。但露西因为她丈夫是个极品而被大家质问，大家还说她应该离开他。
Oh, the whole group confronted her. Well, mind you, this made me laugh. Mind you, this book club is filled with a bunch of what I thought to be vanilla married ladies, and a lot have young kids. Well, Lucy chose to stand by her man and now isn't talking to anyone in the group and told them all off. Daphne wraps it up by saying, I am a mom of a little one and this book club has been a fun way for me to get out of the house and have some adult time one evening a month.
哦，整个群体去质问她。嗯，请注意，这把我逗笑了。请注意，这个读书会里挤满了许多我原本以为是循规蹈矩的已婚女士，而且许多人都有年幼的孩子。嗯，露西选择坚守她的男人，现在不和群里的任何人说话，把他们狠狠痛骂了一通。达芙妮在信的最后写道：我是一个幼儿的妈妈，这个读书会一直是我每月一个晚上能走出家门、享受成人时光的有趣方式。
And I love the good fantasy books. Side note, Angela would love our books. But this whole situation is awkward now. And I'm so happy I wasn't involved and was completely clueless about the whole situation. So what do you think, office ladies? Should I stick out the awkwardness now that I know, or should I leave? And that's the T. Well, I mean, Lucy has told this whole group to F off.
而且我喜欢好的奇幻书。顺便说一句，安吉拉一定会喜欢我们的书。但整个情况现在变得很尴尬。我很庆幸自己没有卷入其中，对整个情况完全一无所知。所以你们觉得呢，办公室女士们？既然我现在知道了，我是应该忍受这种尴尬坚持下去，还是应该退出？这就是爆料的内容。嗯，我的意思是，露西已经让这个群体所有人滚蛋了。
Yeah. Hannah's not coming anymore. I mean, listen, the two problems in this story are not at the book club anymore. That is true. That is true. I guess you just have to wonder, though. When are they going to turn on someone else?
对啊。汉娜也不来了。我的意思是，听着，这个故事里的两个麻烦制造者已经不在读书会里了。这倒也是。这倒也是。不过你大概还是会忍不住想，
Yeah. Are they going to meddle in someone else's marriage and personalize? Have a group meeting to tell you your husband's the worst? Yeah. Well? I mean, there's two ladies who didn't think he was the worst. Apparently.
她们什么时候会把矛头转向别人？是啊。她们会不会去干涉别人的婚姻然后搞得太私人化？开个集体会议来告诉你你的丈夫是个极品？是啊。嗯？我的意思是，还有两个女士不觉得他是极品。显然如此。
Right? But also, like, do book clubs always get that personal? Lady, I know we're getting ready to wrap it up, but I actually have one more letter. OK. Funny you should ask if they get personal. This letter made me chuckle, and it made me think of Phyllis. Our Phyllis? Our Phyllis Lapinvance.
对吧？但同时，读书会总是会变得这么私人化吗？女士，我知道我们准备收尾了，但我其实还有最后一封信。好的。真巧啊，你居然会问它们会不会变得私人化。这封信让我咯咯直笑，还让我想起了菲利斯。我们的菲利斯？我们的菲利斯·拉平凡斯（Phyllis Lapin-Vance）。
Okay. It's from Natalie P. in Nashville, Tennessee, who said, Years ago, our book club read Fifty Shades of Grey. Oh. I remember my friend recommending it and everyone in the room looked uneasy. I had not heard of it, so I spoke up and naively and energetically said, Yeah, let's do it. It's your choice. Natalie said I bought the book, luckily on my iPad, because I brought it to school to read during lunch. I'm a high school teacher. Now I know why you said it makes you think of Phyllis Vance. And Natalie said a few chapters in, I was horrified of what I was reading in broad daylight.
好吧。信来自田纳西州纳什维尔的娜塔莉·P（Natalie P.），她说：多年前，我们的读书会读了《五十度灰》。哦。我记得我的朋友推荐了它，房间里的每个人看起来都局促不安。我没听说过这本书，所以我大声开口，天真而又充满活力地说：好的，就读这本吧。你们选的。娜塔莉说我买下了这本书，好在是用iPad买的，因为我把它带到学校在午餐时读。我是一名高中老师。现在我知道你为什么说这让你想起菲利斯·万斯了。娜塔莉说，读了几章后，我在广天化日之下对我读到的内容感到震惊。
So Natalie said, anyway, in a group of about, this is the part that cracked me up, in a group of about 12 ladies, eight of us got pregnant. The book club fell apart and my husband likes to call the kids the Grabeys. That is so funny. That is fantastic. Oh my goodness. Well everyone, that was our finer things club. We had so much fun prepping this episode, doing this episode, hearing from you about your snooty clubs.
所以娜塔莉说，不管怎样，在大约——这就是让我笑喷的部分——在大约12位女士的群体中，我们有8个人怀孕了。读书会解散了，我丈夫喜欢把这些孩子叫做“格雷宝”（Grabeys）。太搞笑了。这太棒了。天哪。好吧，各位，这就是我们的精致生活俱乐部。我们为筹备这一集、制作这一集、听取你们关于你们那势利俱乐部的故事感到无比开心。
It was just a delight start to finish. This whole work week was so fun, culminating in our tea party with Sam and Cassie. And lady, you know, when we originally broke down Branch Wars, we said we were going to start our own finer things club. We were going to read all the books that they read. I remember. We never did it, but honestly, I think it's because I don't have a huge interest
从头到尾简直是一种享受。整个工作周太有趣了，最终以我们和萨姆、卡西的茶会达到了高潮。女士，你知道的，当我们最初拆解分公司大战（Branch Wars）时，我们说过我们要建立自己的精致生活俱乐部。我们要读他们读过的所有书。我记得。我们从来没这么做过，但老实说，我想这是因为我对他们读的书没有太大兴趣，但我很愿意和你一起办一个精致生活俱乐部。你还记得我们谈过这个吗？记得。我记得。你当时还说我们可以把它叫作“精致人的俱乐部”（Finer's Things Club），因为我总是说不准。我想让你知道，我们在这一集里每一次说出这个词时，我都付出了怎样的精神专注度。
in the books that they read, but I would do a finer things club with you. Do you remember talking about this? I do. I do. And you actually said we could call it Finer's Things Club because I can never say it correctly. And I want you to know the mental focus I have had to have every time we have said it in this episode.
你做得很好。好吧，我结巴了一两次，但我真的必须说出“精致生活俱乐部”（Finer Things Club）。我必须思考一下。而且你知道，上次我们分享过一个我这么做时的笑场花絮，但我们没有播出来。很多人都说：你们应该把花絮播出来。你有吗？
You did great. Well, I stumbled once or twice, but I really had to say Finer Things Club. I had to think about it. And you know, last time we shared that there was a blooper of me doing this, but we didn't play it. And a lot of people were like, you should play the blooper. Do you have it?
我有。哦，你必须播，我想听。好吧。精致生活俱乐部没有问题，但是精致的事……精致的东……精致的事物俱乐部。精致生活俱乐部。
I have it. Oh, you have to play, I wanna hear it. Okay. No problem with the finer things club, but the finer thing. The finer sthings... The finer sthings... The finer sthings club. The finer sthings club.
好吧。精致的事……好吧，女士，我会和你一起开启精致生活俱乐部。我很难说出“finer sthings”。精致生活俱乐部。但和你一起开启“Finers Things Club”。我很难说出“Finers Things”。Finers Things Club。但我会和你一起开启那个俱乐部。不过我只是，我不知道。如果我们的“Finers Things Club”只是四处走走，在不同的地方喝茶，
Okay. The finer sthings... Well, lady, I will start the finer sthings club with you. It's hard for me to say finer sthings. Finer sthings club. But the Finers Things Club with you. It's hard for me to say Finers Things. Finers Things Club. But I'll start that club with you. But I just, I don't know. What if our Finers Things Club is just going around and having tea at different places
然后去艺术博物馆呢？我完全可以接受。如果你不想的话，甚至都不用读任何书。好吧，如果历史今天教给我们什么的话，那就是你和人们一起办读书会，然后它就会分崩离析。是啊。而且他们会像人际关系一样内部爆破。确实如此。
and going to art museums? That is absolutely fine with me. You don't even have to read any books if you don't want to. Well, if history has taught us anything today is that you start a book club with people and it falls apart. Yeah. And they will like relationships implode. It's true.
去美术馆？我完全没问题。如果你不想读，甚至一本书都不用读。好吧，如果今天的历史教导了我们什么的话，那就是你和别人发起一个读书俱乐部最后却会分崩离析。是的。它们会像人际关系一样土崩瓦解。确实如此。
So we can't start one. We also remember we're going to start an office ladies movie club that we never did as well. Okay. Well, I like this idea of tea and art, museums and movies. Great. The Finer's Things Club. The Finer's Things Club. We'll leave that book drama at the door.
所以我们不能办一个。我们还记得我们要成立一个办公室女士电影俱乐部，结果也没办成。好吧。嗯，我很喜欢这个关于茶艺、艺术、博物馆和电影的主意。太棒了。“精致生活俱乐部”。“精致生活俱乐部”。我们要把那些书本上的抓马留在门外。
Okay, before we go, I have one last thing I wanna share. I thought it might be a fun way to end this episode since we started with Andy. There is a deleted scene where we learn Andy's fate about joining the Finer Things club. Let's hear it Dear Andrew Bernard after carefully examining your application to the finer things club We are unable to offer you a position at this place in time We would however like to place you on a list in case an opportunity arises when your inclusion could be tolerated
好的，在我们离开之前，我还有最后一件事想分享。我想这可能是结束这一集的一个有趣方式，因为我们是从安迪开始的。有一个被删减的片段，我们知道了安迪关于加入“精致生活俱乐部”的命运。我们听听看：“亲爱的安迪·伯纳德，在仔细审阅了你加入精致生活俱乐部的申请后，我们目前无法为你提供一个职位。不过，如果有机会让你的加入能够被容忍的话，我们愿意将你列入候补名单……”
Your position as an ongoing financial patron, however, is yours to cherish. Sincerely, the finer things club. Yes! Woohoo! Waitlisted! He's so excited. And you see Pam and Toby and Oscar over at front reception, they're watching him open this letter. It's really funny.
然而，你作为持续财务赞助商的地位依然属于你，值得珍惜。署名：精致生活俱乐部。耶！太棒了！候补了！他太兴奋了。你可以看到帕姆、托比和奥斯卡在前台接待处，他们看着他打开这封信。真的很搞笑。
Aw, waitlisted for the finer things club. It's perfect. Well, thank you everyone. Thanks for writing in. Thanks for listening today. We love you. We love you. That was so much fun.
啊，进入了精致生活俱乐部的候补名单。太完美了。好吧，谢谢大家。谢谢你们的来信。谢谢你们今天的收听。我们爱你们。我们爱你们。这太有趣了。
We hope you have a great week. See you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
希望大家过个愉快的一周。下周见。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。Audyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。